es un retroceso para los derechos de las
personas
lgtbiq más en uganda este martes el
parlamento aprobó una ley que prohíbe
identificarse como lgtbiq+ esta cámara
no temerá restringir ningún derecho en
la medida en que reconozca proteja y
salvaguarde la soberanía de este país la
moral de este país las culturas bueno
Wanda la homosexualidad ella es ilegal
como en más de 30 países en África pero
es el primero según la organización
Human Rights en prohibir el mero hecho
de identificarse como lesbiana bisexual
transexual o queer el motivo que dan las
fuerzas conservadoras representa una
amenaza para los valores tradicionales
básica de nuestra sociedad es la familia
si destruyes la familia destruyes
nuestra sociedad
afirmaciones que atentan contra la
dignidad de las personas en un país en
el que los miembros del colectivo ya
sufren a persecución como denuncia a
Erick noadula activista lgtbiq más de 26
años al que echaron de su casa alquilada
después de reconocerlo como homosexual
llegó un individuo que decidió hacer un
video sobre mí y el trabajo que hago
online lo compartió en Facebook y en
cuestión de minutos se hizo viral mi
casero me trajo el video con una orden
de desahucio la mañana siguiente
además de las relaciones entre personas
del mismo sexo la ley prohíbe la
promoción y la conspiración sobre la
homosexualidad y las condenas por
infracción son muy severas desde cadena
perpetua hasta incluso pena de muerte